some people can be sort of benign
narcissists where they want great things
for themselves right but if they have
enough great things they can sort of
tolerate others being happy too and and
these are people who sometimes are
actually quite highly liked right
because they have to have the most money
the most power the most of anything
anything more than anyone else could
challenge but as long as I have that
it's okay that you have some too right
and then that can make you happy and can
make you like me right so so benign
narcissists can be can be well liked
from that perspective but
it's still all about them and that can
change if for example there's a scarcity
of resources now right but but they're
generally they're not people who are
being overtly destructive although that
they're over the border into the you
know into the Envy territory right
malignant narcissists are very different
where they then want to have everything
so they so even if I have a thousand
times more than you do I Still Envy you
what you have because I want to have I
don't think I can feel good enough about
myself unless I have everything and once
I have everything I won't feel good
enough about myself either and I don't
have to have more right it's like that's
malignant narcissism which we we think
of as sociopathy right as we can we can
Define these words in different ways but
they're very very negative Concepts you
know it's that's that's profound
sociopathy malignant narcissism uh you
know Envy writ large sociopathy is
malignant narcissism that's a convenient
way to think about it
uh no because we can do sort of
sociopathic things that but not be
sociopathic like well you know I tell a
white lie it's it's like sort of
sociopathy on steroids right is is then
you know Envy writ large is malignant
narcissists well just like you're saying
like uh there's empathic Attunement as
you said so there's the the mechanistic
aspect of empathy and sociopathy and
then there's the big label you get
attached if you're just doing that thing
regularly I guess living your life
through that lens yeah right yeah and uh
is there a nice Spectrum that's like
narcissism sociopathy and psychopathy is
it all the same kind of a nice stroll
through the woods off the cliff not
really because the
don't have clear definitions like
psychopathy and sociopathy there's no
there's no there's no real definition of
psychopath or psychopathy or does that
mean someone's sociopathic but psychotic
like there's really not a we end up
using those words colloquially right
which is why you know Concepts that we
can Define like you like Envy empathic
Attunement
um narcissism even though there might be
nuances and definitions like we can
Define them in ways that are widely
accepted including within psychology and
Psychiatry so it's nice to just think
about this a broad umbrella of
narcissism and the levels to which it's
benign or malignant and then also
separating into the different mechanisms
like interaction by interaction which
sometimes can be narcissistic but
broadly speaking do you do everything
through the lens of malignant narcissism
that makes you a
sociopath or
a malignant narcissist yes and the thing
I would I would add to that is the
thought about culture right it's like
how does the the cultures were in
whether it's the culture of a household
right the culture of a community the
culture of a Nation or the world right
how does that impact what unfolds in
that person and then how does what
unfolds in that person impact that
culture